Ukraine
Ukraine is Longing For Peace Europe is
Longing For Peace the world is saying it
doesn't want any War while Russia is
claiming she doesn't want to intervene
someone here is lying this is not yet an
axiom but by far north only a hypothesis
two I visited the separation line in the
dawn bus just a couple of days ago in
legal terms this is line separating
Ukraine and temporary occupied territory
but in real terms this is this the line
separating peace and the war the line
with the kindergarten on the one hand
and the shell flying into it on the one
hand the school and on the other hand
the shell flying into the school
playground with 30 kids nearby on the
other hand the kids who are not heading
towards NATO they are heading towards
their classrooms some of them might be
having their physics classes and with
their Elementary knowledge of physics
even these kids will know that alleging
that it was Ukraine to have a shelled
these objects is just silly other kids
might as well be having their math
classes they don't need a calculator to
figure out the difference between the
total number of shelling in the last two
days in the number of times Ukraine is
mentioned in the Munich security report
yet some kids might be having their
history class and so when they see the
the shell crater in their playground
instead of their school playground they
might start asking questions has our
world completely forgotten the mistakes
of the 20th century where does the
appeasement policy usually usually leads
to how did we get from the question
what's the point of dying for dancing to
dozens of millions having to die away
give away their lives for
as well as dozens of other European
cities there's a horrific history
lessons with this I'm simply trying to
make sure we have been reading the same
textbook so that we are all on the same
page about one main question how do we
get to this point in the 21st century
where the war is being waged and people
are dying in Europe how come they're
time wise it's already longer than World
War II how did we end up in the biggest
security crisis since the end of the
Cold War to me as a president of the
country which lost part of its territory
thousands of people the country
surrounded by a hundred fifty thousand
army with heavy Armament and Machinery
on our borders to me this answer is
obvious the security architecture of our
world is brittle it is obsolete the
rules that have been agreed upon by the
world dozens of years ago are no longer
working they are neither catching up
with the new rats not being effective in
overcoming them just like a cough syrup
instead of a good covet vaccine this
security system is slow and failing us
time and time again because of different
things egotism arrogance and
irresponsibility of countries on the
global level as a result some countries
are committing crimes While others
resort to indifference the indifference
that turn them into accomplices it is
symbolic that I'm saying this here 15
years ago it was Russian Federation who
made the statement here and putting the
challenge to the Global Security how did
the world respond appeasement what do we
have as a result the annexation of the
crime and aggression against my country
at the very least the U.N which was
initially called to to safeguard pieces
security cannot protect itself when its
own Charter being violated as one one of
the security Council Members annexing
the territory of another founding member
while the U.N itself is ignoring the
Crimean platform established to do
occupy the Crimea and advocate for the
rights of the Crimean tatters it was
here three years ago when Angela Merkel
said who can pick up the pieces of the
world's puzzle only all of us together
she said to rush to a rush of audible
excitement in the room which stood up to
applaud unfortunately the collective
evasion failed to transform into
Collective action so now that the world
is talking about the thread of a big war
it begs the question is there anything
left to pick up the security
architecture of Europe and Beyond is
almost destroyed it's too late now to
talk about fixing it it's high time for
a new one the mankind did so on two
occasions having paid an extensively
High prize it is the two World Wars we
do have a chance to break that trend
um before it became a trend and built a
new system before we pay millions of
casualties with uh on basement
experience of two world wars without the
third one to come in here in uni and in
the U.N already mentioned that there is
no such thing as it is not my war in the
25th Century that annexation of the
Crimea and the war in the downpasses
have blow to the whole world that this
is not about war in Ukraine this is
about the war in Europe I mentioned this
in 2019 2020
2021 will their world be able to hear me
in 2022. this is no longer a hypothesis
but not yet an axioms why not because it
requires proof it requires something
more than just tweets and statements in
mass media action is needed the world
needs this action not Ukraine we are
going to protect our country with or
without support of our partners bid
hundreds pieces of contemporary Armament
or five thousand helmets we equally
appreciate the support but everyone
needs to understand that this is not
some kind of donation Ukraine should be
reminding of begging for this is not
just a broad gesture that Ukraine should
be bowing down for this is your
contribution into the European and
International Security for which Ukraine
has been serving as a shield for eight
years now a reliable Shield holding back
one of the largest armies in the world
that same Army which is now poised on
the Ukrainian not EU member states
borders and the
missiles were flying into the mariupal
north the European cities and things
over and after the fights and the
destroyed airport internet
not in Frankfurt and it is always
blazing
industrial Zone which is being shelled
there it was very hot not in more months
and none of the countries of Europe know
what the military funerals are around
the country in all regions and none of
the European leaders knows what is it to
regularly meet with the families of the
dead soldiers no matter what we're going
to protect our beautiful land
on our borders
either we have 150
000 to 1 million soldiers of any army in
order to help Ukraine indeed we don't
need to hear how many of them are there
and how many Armament they have we need
to hear how many are there of us
together to help Ukraine we don't need
to be reminded of the dates of the
plausible intervention we're going to
protect our land on the 16th of June
February on the 1st of March and the
31st them but we need other days much
more than these days and everyone
understands what kind of dates tomorrow
is the day of commemoration of the
Heavenly hundred AIDS yes ago ukrainians
have made their choice and many of them
have sacrificed their lives for that do
you think that eight years later Ukraine
should keep calling for acknowledgment
of our European perspective since 2014
Russia is convincing everyone that this
was an erroneous past part for Ukraine
that no one is waiting for us in Europe
isn't it Europe that should be saying
and proving them wrong isn't it Europe
we should be saying today that our
citizens have a positive attitude
towards Ukraine joining the Union why
are we avoiding this question doesn't
Ukraine deserve to have direct and Frank
answers the same is true about nature so
we are told the doors are open but but
so far the strangers are not allowed if
not all the members are willing to see
us there or all members don't want to
see us there be honest about it open
doors are good but we need open answers
but not the years and years of closed
questions is isn't the right for truth
part of our opportunities and the sooner
the better the sooner Summit in Madrid
for example the Russian Federation is
saying that Ukraine is wants to join
NATO to bring the Crimean back by force
it's good to hear that bring back the
crime is something that they mentioned
their rhetoric but they didn't read
carefully Article Five of the NATO
Charter the collective uh actions are
for protection or for attack the crime
and the occupied land of donbass will
come back to Ukraine but only through
peaceful process Ukraine is consistent
about Normandy and Minsk agreement their
Foundation is the recognition of the
territorial integrity and Independence
of our state we want to have diplomatic
resolution of the military conflict
exclusively I would like to emphasize
based on their international law so what
in reality is happening now in Minsk in
the peaceful process two years ago with
the president of France and Russian
Federation and German Chancellor we
agreed about a full fled ceasefire and
Ukraine is committed to these agreements
and we observing them we are we keep not
responding to the provocations we're
submitting proposals to the Normandy
foreign trilateral content groups and
Double C instead shelling and bullets
our soldiers will be are dying our
peaceful population is dying civil
infrastructure being destroyed the last
two days have become very
symbolic
massive shelling from the Armament
prohibited by the Minsk agreement it's
important
to allow for The Observers for the osc
to visit they are being threatened
they're being scared all humanitarian
questions of being blocked too years ago
I've signed into law the unconditional
access of humanitarian organizations to
the detainees but on the temporary
occupied territories they're simply not
allowed after two exchange of prisoners
there's process has been stalled
although and blocked although Ukraine
has been sharing the approved lists
torches until the death in the uh
notorious isolation prison isolation
prison indones now is the symbol of
human provides violation in November the
two new Crossing points that we opened
in lugan's koblast have not been put
into operation and we see this and as an
obstruction under false pretext and
Ukraine is doing its best to push this
discussion to put discussion for
political questions as well in the TCG
in the men's process we have submitted
the proposals and the drafts of law but
everything is blocked and no one is
talking about them
Ukraine demands
urgently to unblock the negotiation
process at the same time this does not
mean that looking for peace is limited
and restricted only by that we are
prepared to look for the keys in to end
the war in all possible formats and all
possible platforms but in Paris means
Istanbul Beijing Barcelona it doesn't
matter
where in the world will we will agree
about the peace in Ukraine four
countries will be there seven countries
will be a hundred countries it doesn't
matter the most important Russia and
Ukraine to be there what is important is
the understanding there we need not only
us who need peace the the world needs
peace we need to restore uh base and
integrity in the internationally
acknowledged borders and I hope no one
is thinking about Ukraine as a permanent
buffer between the Russian Federer
nation in the west this will never
happen no one allows this to happen
other ways there will be a question who
is next NATO countries will have to
protect each other I would I want to
believe that North Atlantic Treaty in
Article 5 will be more effective than
the Budapest memorandum
for the refusal
the fact that we refuse for the from the
third biggest nuclear power we receive
the current security guarantees we are
no longer we don't don't we no longer
have that weapon neither do we have the
security we have lost parts of our
territory which is bigger in territory
than
Switzerland Netherlands or Belgium
millions of citizens who have been lost
all of that has
been lost but we have to still have
something we have the right to demand to
move from the appeasement policy to
ensuring the guarantees of security
since 2014 three times Ukraine has tried
to call for consultations for the
guarantors of the countries who
guaranteed The Budapest agreement three
times no success this will be the fourth
time today that we're going to do this
as a president for the first time but
both Ukraine and me is going we'll do
this the last time we are initiating
under Budapest memorandum
the foreign minister to have this
meeting and if at the result of this
we're not going to guarantee of Defense
after this Summit we will think that
Budapest memorandum is not working it's
and all the package decisions of 1994
have been put in question and
compromised
in the nearest weeks I propose to call
the summit of the countries of the
security Council with the participation
of Europe Germany and turkey to resolve
security challenges in Europe and come
up with new effective guarantees
security guarantees for Ukraine the
guarantees that
we need before we become the members of
the defense Council being in this gray
Zone in a security vacuum so to speak
what else can we do now we can continue
the effective support of Ukraine and its
defense capabilities providing the
European perspective providing the
support as are provided to the candidate
countries and providing specific
timelines for Ukraine possible
membership in their Alliance we need
support for the transformation in our
country to create the stability and
restoration fund a land lease program
supplying new Armament and equipment to
our army the Army which is protecting
the whole Europe an effective preventive
sanctions package is what we need to
restrain the aggression and the energy
integration of the Ukraine into European
Union in the times when not stream 2 is
being used as a weapon all these
questions require answers instead there
is silence and while this silence
persists there will be no silence in the
east of Ukraine in the east of Europe
and in the whole world I do hope finally
the whole world will understand this in
Europe will understand this is ladies
and gentlemen I'm very grateful to the
countries who have supported Ukraine
with their words with their declaration
and specific support those who are on
our side on the side of Truth on the
side of international law I'm not
calling my friends out by names I don't
want some countries to be ashamed but
this is their business this is their
matter these are their countries their
karma and this is their Consciousness
that they have to look into I although I
don't know how they will be able to
explain these actions to the two people
who were killed and three wounded
Ukrainian soldiers today and three
girls from KU ten six and one years old
who don't have a father any longer at
six o'clock in the morning East European
time when Ukrainian
Scout officer was killed from the
altario
shall prohibited by Minsk I don't know
what he thought about at the last second
of his life
he didn't really for sure understand
what kind of agenda we need for the
meeting to stop the war in the East but
what he knew is the answer to the
question that I asked at the very
beginning he very well knows who is
lying here
rest in peace
to him and to all those who have died
for the enduring these years of all in
the east of our country thank you
thank you
[Applause]
Mr President you gave a very impassioned
speech just now and we'll get to it in a
moment but first I want to ask you that
I'm not sure how many people in this
room expected you to make the decision
to leave your country and come here
today what was so important for you to
be here and what do you know about
Vladimir Putin's intentions that perhaps
the United States or others don't know
because they think that he's made the
decision to enter your country
thank you very much
thank you for this question and thank
you for your for the invitation it is
very important uh when Ukraine is being
discussed
for Ukraine for these for this
information to count from the mouth of
our of of our country
um I'm the president and our team it's
important for all our partners and
friends not to agree about anything
behind our back and I do believe in our
partnership and I do believe that this
is the case
um and uh I had I had very important
meetings today with the leaders of
different countries and uh still more to
go and I would like you to hear to see
to ask questions and get the answers to
understand the level of resilience of
our country that we're not panicking
we're very consistent that we are not
responding to any provocations
we have our own vaccine already
developed for that not as good as kovid
vaccines but this vaccine is already
eight years old we know know the things
we need to react to and things we
shouldn't of course when our soldiers
are being killed we know we need to
respond but we understand who is killing
us we understand what these military
groups are
but and we also understand when they are
shooting from the localities surrounded
by civilians to provoke us for us to
respond and to start an escalation or
the other side in response to the to our
fire
it's also important for me for us to be
on the same page in terms of information
the the fact that the partners are
sharing with us the information we're
very grateful for that by the way for
the cooperation of our intelligences but
we are in this tension for many many
years now we do not think that we need
to panic we think these risks are indeed
very high because we have more troops
150 000 troops on our borders yes indeed
that's a big risk but a very big risk if
we respond if we do respond to one
provocation or the other
on the other hand I think that Russian
Federation and we when we are talking
about Russia this this is the people the
whole people of Russia so I think they
will not be able to start to go to war
against Ukraine and although on the
temporary occupied territories we have a
lot of provocations and we see them we
see this how through the mass media
they're disseminating different
provocative information we need to
preserve our stability we need to keep
calm and be adults uh are these from
this in this terms Ukraine Army is more
adult than others
competition on the so-called false flag
issues you have just talked about two
Ukrainian soldiers being killed the
Russians say mines have exploded
Ukrainian mines on their side of the
Border we've seen this rhetoric before
we understand the concept of false Flags
but how tense is that how do you think
you can stop it you know how do you
consider the level of the current
provocations
any provocations are very dangerous as I
already said I think the most
complicated question that in the Crimea
in the temporary occupied territory of
the donbass along the borders of Ukraine
and Russia
there's 30 35
000 on the temporary why or temporary
occupancy which is 35 000 more and 150
along other borders so provocations are
indeed very dangerous if you have this
number of troops one shelling one fire a
cannon fire can lead to a war and we
perfectly understand as I said I do
think so and this is what our partners
believe I mean the partners that are
around us who have joined borders with
us we know the history of the Soviet
Union and they do understand the kind of
risks we are facing the Poland the
Baltic states Lithuanian Estonia foreign
much more casualties unfortunately
when someone in the in mass media says
that now this is the most horrific
situation that is not true it is
horrible it's a tragedy for our nation
for our people it is a tragedy and in
future you will see that this is the
tragedy for Russians as well who used to
have good relationship with Ukraine how
do we stay members neighbors and live
with each other from now on but uh we're
in a different point of our uh life
we're not talking about neighborhood we
are talking about the war and then it
shouldn't start this is why the risk is
high what was shown yesterday on the
temporary occupying territory there
shown some shelling allegedly flying
from our side and then they have shown
something flying all the way to the
stove region of Russia this is just me a
blunt provocation these are pure lies
there's no one dead or wounded this is
just cynicism of such a high level that
they are blowing up something on their
side and and shooting this is not the
first time since 2014 that they are
aiming their guns and
shooting at the territory that they
themselves control this is the kind of
cynicism that's it and we all we care is
about is peace and I mentioned this many
times to the president of Russian
Federation and uh
in 2019 and we have sent a massive
amount of signals on the monthly basis
we have been passing on to different
world leaders and directly to Russian
federations that we are ready to sit
down and speak
the platform that you like pick the
partners that will be there around the
table with us we are ready for that
prepared for that what's the point of us
shooting and proposing diplomacy at the
same time
I'm too long I'm sorry
you you can stop me when when you want
excuse how you
prepared to a few days ago because I
think everybody's being quite amazed at
this solidarity between the United
States and your country and Europe and
the united front that's been presented
and also the extraordinary departure
that the United States has used
intelligence to Telegraph exactly what
it sees President Putin doing you have
said different things about that that on
the one hand it could so panic and
you're going to remain disciplined and
you just said again we're not going to
panic how do you evaluate the U.S
aggressive use of intelligence to try to
dissuade President Putin
foreign
it's difficult for me to judge
how United States should be using their
intelligence I guess they're doing this
in a professional manner this is their
choice but I'm grateful for the work
that both of our intelligence has been
doing but the intelligence I trust is my
intelligence I trust
Ukrainian intelligence who are now
territory who understand what's going on
along our borders who have different
intelligent sources and understand
different uh risk-based or intercepted
data we're talking about this and this
information should be used I repeated
this many times we're not uh really
living
in delusion we understand what can
happen to happen tomorrow but maybe the
comparison I will make is not good but
just putting ourselves in coffins and
waiting for foreign soldiers to come in
is not something we are prepared to do
we are not going to advance on anyone
but we stand ready for to respond to
everything we cannot remain passive we
cannot say on the daily basis that war
will happen tomorrow what kind of state
will it is it going to be what kind of
economy is it going to be how can you
live in the state when on the daily
basis you're being told that tomorrow
the war will happen tomorrow the advance
will happen it means crushing National
currency money is being taken out
business flying out can you live in that
kind of country can you have a stability
in that kind of country no and those who
want to disbalance our country from
within a multiple and everyone wants
Ukraine to be weak weak economy weak
Army and if there's weak Army you can
just go ahead and invade and we won't be
able to protect neither of people
neither our children or the economy this
is why our response is very to come
to one piece of inflation or the other
we have to assess it we have to think
not how to react to what I just got but
I have to digest this information I have
to understand what will happen after my
words up to my reaction to this what
happened to my people
what will happen after these people will
run to the banks to take money from
their deposit accounts after they start
fearing and the Panic will start uh we
have the information War the hybrid war
going on this is why ukrainians are not
giving up
indifferent
sense of this word we want to live day
after day and protect our country if you
want to help us we have lots of examples
from this information
a lot of uh very concrete things
strengthen our arms give us more
Armament strengthen our economy invest
in our
country bring your business in if you're
afraid okay give us cheap financing give
us support Finance Grant support why
um when we're giving money why we're
always getting these connections you
have to get to one two three four five
six seven and dozen of other reforms is
there any other country
in the world who would have such a
strong Army on the Eastern borders with
all these reforms implemented at the
same time that is not easy but we're not
panicking we just live our lives we want
to live in it as a strong country that's
it
Mr President talked again about nature
I'm sorry I just wanted to add I'm sorry
for for interrupting you sorry
we had a discussion some time ago with
one of the leaders of one of the leading
countries and we were talking about the
sanction policy where he had a different
Vision on how sanctions should be
applied when Russian aggression will
happen and we are being told that you
have several days and then the war will
start and I said okay then apply the
sanctions today
yes they say yes we apply sanctions when
the war will happen I'm saying fine but
you are telling me that it's 100 that
the war will start in a couple of days
when then what are you waiting for we
don't need your sanctions after the
bombardment will happen and after our
country will to be fired dad or after we
will have no borders now after we will
have no economy or part of our countries
will be occupied why would we need those
sanctions then what is this about so
when you're asking what can be done
well lots of different things can be
done we can even provide you the list
the most important is willingness
so you're calling for for sanctions to
be leveled now you also talked about
NATO now there's obviously this is the
big sensitive issue in this whole issue
right and you have just talked about
again wanting to be part of NATO and yet
you said you don't expect any NATO
soldiers on your territory now you
specifically said we want no foreign
Soldiers with foreign flags on our sold
on our territory right now what is your
position on wanting to join NATO today
to respond to the first part of your
question about sanctions the question is
not about introducing them today
if the whole world understands that
tomorrow there is a high probability of
escalation by Russian Federation and if
Russian Federation is not pulling out
their military I think that would be a
powerful step if they are pulling back
then there will be no question that's a
soft option I'm talking about the
diplomats who cannot apply sanctions
automatically I'm talking about the
logic if they pull back their troops
well there will be no sanctions
but today even the question of just
making it public preventively just the
list of sanctions for them for Usher to
know what will happen if they start the
war even that question does not have the
support okay let's be honest then then
I have a question why if you can't even
disclose what will happen
to to whom if the war starts then the
question is that it will be I I doubt
that it will be triggered after even
happens
in terms of NATO we had a lot of debates
regard regarding this and there were
lots of discussions about the world
leaders and my friends
meanwhile I have lots of friends among
the world leaders I will not name them
because others will get offended Ukraine
is being supported indeed but Ukraine
needs security guarantees we are smart
people we are not narrow-minded we
understand there are lots of different
reasons because of NATO there is no
consensus around
the Allies everyone is saying there is
some distance that we need to to go
between Ukraine and the NATO that we
need to walk all we are saying is tell
us how much time does it take to
complete this distance measured in years
and you see this this is measured not
just in hours and you can see with the
tragedies and lives this is measured in
the human life of ukrainians so tell us
on this distance
is it fair for us to get the guarantees
why we're still walking this path some
diplomatic guarantees isn't it just
simply Fair no one is pushing anyone
against the wall with a question for us
to be there in the NATO that's not the
case we want to we do but unless but
until we have that possibility what we
want is the guarantees security
guarantees
and I know you have to go I'm getting
the the old wrap but can I ask you just
just a second I think I think
Cyber attack
[Laughter]
can I have another one
for translation
yes but maybe you maybe here but they're
here
that's that well it doesn't work I'm
sorry I
tried to talk to you and you'll you'll
understand me you draw I I understand
you from the very beginning but you know
there are some
very important things yeah so what I
want to ask you Mr President is that the
U.S has its intelligence you said you
have yours what is your interpretation
of Putin's intention not his capability
his intention do you think that he will
invade he will decide to do that or he
has
known I don't know what the president of
Russian Federation wants that's why I
propose to meet
that's it
[Laughter]
on that note
your people are telling me that I have
to say on Syria huh sorry your people
are telling me that you need to go
were you at all afraid of coming here
why there are friends here no no leaving
your house unguarded
um
well my response would be very brief I'm
sure that our country is in good hands
this is not just my hands these are the
hands of our soldiers and our citizens I
think me please my visit here is
important
and I would like to say that I had
breakfast in the morning in Ukraine and
I will have my uh a dinner in Ukraine as
well I never leave home for long
thank you so much uh at uh DW's Chief
International editor Richard Walker is
standing by for us at the Munich
security conference Richard uh what was
your main takeaway from that speech
yeah well Monica I would certainly agree
with some of your uh your summary just
there
um quite an emotional tone and a
frustrated tone from Vladimir zielinski
at various parts of his speech and just
ending there on an emotional note
talking about two people uh recently
just killed in the region where this
turbulence is going on and asking how he
explains to uh how he would have
explained to them what's been going on
in terms of diplomacy in terms of the
international support that that Ukraine
is receiving or in his eyes not
receiving sufficiently and I think maybe
what I would pull out of this speech by
zelenski is maybe he's he knows what his
audience is here and that his audience
is not necessarily the Russians but that
his audience is
um the countries which are ostensibly
supporting Ukraine and sort of throwing
down the gauntlet to them to some extent
on some of the key questions here for
instance
um NATO uh Ukraine's desire to join NATO
now the Western allies the NATO alliance
have been insisting in their
negotiations with Vladimir Putin that
the idea that NATO has an open door that
any country can apply to join NATO that
this is a core principle of NATO
well Vladimir zielinski saying well if
this door is open
please tell me if there are any
countries who really don't want us
because the door is notionally open to
them but they don't see any a progress
there so he actually pushing for a
timeline for Ukraine to join NATO around
the same time that most western leaders
are suggesting that the prospect of NATO
membership if there is a prospect at all
is a pretty distant one for Ukraine so I
think that one example of zelenski sort
of suggesting that Ukraine feels strung
along to some extent by Western powers
in the face of this aggression from
Russia right and you just mentioned also
that he knew his audience he knew who he
was talking to did you get a feel a
sense of how his speech was received by
the delegates in Munich he got roaring
Applause right at the beginning and as
soon as he mentions soldiers it sort of
died down abruptly uh what was your
impression
yeah well I think I mean that was very
striking at the beginning the the uh
Standing Ovation for him of course that
should be no surprise I mean the
circumstances of him coming here it has
to be stress really are quite
extraordinary uh Ukraine under the
threat potentially of imminent Invasion
and the President coming here to Munich
uh to call for support
um but of course A lot of these messages
that he has for Western powers for the
Americans and four others are quite
slightly uncomfortable ones particularly
for example with respect to Germany now
we were just talking earlier uh before
uh zelenski took to the stage about
Germany's position on supplying arms to
Ukraine defensive arms the Germans
saying that they don't want to do that
for historical reasons also pointing to
the fact that they are meant to be
acting as mediators between the
ukrainians and the Russians in the
Diplomatic process around this crisis
um well zelenski not calling out Germany
by name but a couple of glancing
mentions to Germany won't have gone
unnoticed by the German delegations here
referring to the 5 000 helmets that we
just mentioned earlier that the Germans
are supplying but not going Beyond a
protective helmet this is seen a a
pretty caustically by the ukrainians and
also by by some other
Western allies so an uncomfortable
message also at least between the lines
from zelenski to the German hosts here
right and Richard just for those who are
joining us just now we do have a short
snippet out of Vladimir zelenski's
speech I believe it's uh also the one
where he reiterates again that what they
really want what Ukraine really wants is
is peace let's just listen in
ukraina
Ukraine is Longing For Peace Europe is
Longing For Peace the world is saying it
doesn't want any War while Russia is
claiming she doesn't want to intervene
someone here is lying
someone there is lying is what I
mentioned earlier I think he's pointing
there straight into the direction of of
Moscow the Kremlin and interesting
enough everybody at the Munich security
conference was stressing how important
diplomacy is yet Russia is not attending
is diplomacy just wishful thinking by
the West at this stage
well the fact is that we don't really
know yet Monica there are so many
interpretations of what's actually going
on here what is Vladimir Putin doing
with this massive military buildup now
one significant Theory and we in recent
weeks in recent months has been that the
amassing of troops and the holding of
all of these exercises around Ukraine
um has been not necessarily preparation
to invade but the presentation of a
military threat to invade to go hand in
hand with a push on the Diplomatic front
to extract concessions from the West
over Russian security particularly for
example to say that NATO will no longer
expand I.E to rule out that Ukraine
would join NATO so is this military
buildup simply something which is is
going hand in hand with a diplomatic
push well the closer we get to a
possible Invasion the less likely that
uh that um understanding appears of
course because if the Russians really do
appear employees to invade and and the
sense of of the pushing for a pretext in
eastern Ukraine that we've seen over the
last 24 36 48 hours does point in that
direction then that might suggest that
Vladimir Putin was never really serious
about the Diplomatic sort of arm of what
he's been doing here but the honest fact
is that people don't really know and
it's only Joe Biden the U.S president
who last night said that he believes
that Putin has now made that decision
that's a that's a rare voice of of
certainty in this whole situation
um most western leaders and and people
like Jen stoltenberg we were just
referring to earlier the Secretary
General of NATO they really look more at
the sort of capabilities that you see in
the region and think well the capability
is there so that may mean that the
intention is there too exactly and
interesting enough it's not just Russia
missing this munic security conference
uh China too and we've certainly seen uh
in the in the recent past also for the
opening of the Olympic Games in Beijing
uh that Moscow and Beijing assume to get
on really well and there are closer ties
being forged I believe you had a chance
to talk to the Chinese foreign Secretary
of foreign minister there did he have
anything to say about this current
crisis
yeah so Monica we weren't actually
speaking to the the Chinese foreign
minister
um there is no Chinese delegation here
in Munich but he did take part uh in the
conference but via uh satellite link so
he did take part in in an event here he
gave a speech and then took part in a
conversation with the chairman of the of
the conference here and this was very
interesting to watch
um because as you say we've seen uh
increasing signs of a growing closeness
between Russia and China and this
raising alarm bells in the west that
that
um if Russia and China grow closer and
closer together that this only increases
the challenges that the West are facing
but Wang Yi's message on what's going on
at the moment was quite uh well it
seemed sort of seeming to straddle
um both well different sides of this
situation so on the one hand he was very
supportive of what the Russians are
calling for in terms of
um security guarantees from the West so
Russia is demanding that the West State
NATO will no longer agree expand Wang Yi
very clearly uh undertone underscored
that message uh said that he the Chinese
also believe in that but when asked by
volkang ishinger the chair of this
conference
um whether
China's official commitment to
territorial Integrity of all nation
states I.E all members of the United
Nations a wang Yi did explicitly say
that yes uh Ukraine is no exception so
there will be some things that the
Russians would have been pleased to hear
from the Chinese there that they agreed
that NATO should no longer expand but
the rest of the world would have been
would have been pleased to hear those
words from Wang Yi about the territorial
Integrity of Ukraine so quite a mixed
message from China very interesting to
hear that well thank you so much Richard
also for clarifying the contact next in
which this conversation took place thank
you so much Richard Walker there DW's
Chief International
editor following the Munich security
conference for us thank you